welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss in the latest trailer footage for
hawkeye on disney plus and this latest
dick the halls themed promo reveals some
new details like yet another naughty
lister ruining christmas for the barton
family so i'm gonna break down all the
new stuff we have learned headed into
this six episode hawkeye series that's
gonna get us through the holiday season
but before i begin this video is brought
to you by squarespace from websites and
online stores to marketing tools and
analytics squarespace is the all-in-one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence and run your business here we
go
can i tell you a secret
i'm working with an avenger
[Music]
can i speak to your manager
didn't realize we're still spring guns
so kate bishop played by haley steinfeld
is clint barton's protege future member
of the young avengers is here in our
elevator bragging to a neighbor about
working with an avenger and the sign
behind her lists the elevator's capacity
as six people which i just gotta say is
the same number of people in the og
avengers lineup perhaps the number of
people who are gonna be in the young
avengers and remember they did make hulk
take the stairs when they arrested loki
and that elevator six was the number of
people that tony stark set as the weight
limit just saying between this and the
infinity stones there is something about
the number six in the mcu being the
cosmic limit to the gravity of
everything next there's a new look at
the characters echo and kazzy echo
played by eliquid cox is a death
mercenary with enhanced reflexes she's
worked for kingpin in the past and her
father was actually killed by kingpin
but to her right is kazi aka the clown a
character from the 2013 matt fraction
david hawkeye comic run that this whole
series is based on he's a mercenary who
has also worked for kingpin and is
connected with the tracksuit dracula's
gang that will be a big part of this
series no minor spoiler warning but the
clown does end up killing clint's
neighbor grylls as a way to harass clint
and try to get to him and since this
series seems to be adapting the comics
in a way to make kate bishop the tenant
of the building that the tracksuit
draculas are trying to claim his turf
i'm now really worried about that
friendly old man that kate talks to
could end up bean grylls and he could
end up getting targeted by kazi or the
other tracksuits clint asks the
tracksuits can i speak to your manager
now the leader of the tracksuit draculas
is a guy named ivan but if you think
about it in the comics the track suits
are actually working for wilson fisk
kingpin so yes i think we all really do
want to speak to the top manager of this
operation and then kate trying to rescue
clint crashes in through the skylight
putting her in the same mess that he is
and says didn't realize we were supposed
to bring guns then we see more shots of
the ice rink in 30 rockefeller plaza
that this series is going to be shooting
a lot of action scenes in as well as
more shots of clint larping with some
other kids in the woods now he has a cut
on his head here meaning this could be
after at least his initial run-in with
the gang and he may be trying to track
down who that masked kid cosplaying as
himself showed up on the tv was assuming
this would be a good place to look so he
play fights kid after kid until one of
them legitimately knocks him on his ass
and that will be the girl he's looking
for and clint says it's almost christmas
and i can't go home until i fix this so
in this die hard style action comedy
initially this really isn't clint's
problem but he does get dragged into it
anyway and he can't enjoy christmas
until he fixes it it is possible that
one of his past attacks on organized
crime like against the yakuza or the
mexican cartel we heard about an end
game could have created a power
imbalance with several street gangs in
american cities that allowed the
tracksuit draculas and perhaps kingpin
pull in their strings to ascend in these
urban terp wars so yeah clint feels
responsibility in helping bring them
down we see clint on the phone and from
the change of plans promo last week we
know linda cardellini is returning in
this series as his wife laura barton we
also see the exterior of the broadway
theater show that clint brings his kids
to rogers the musical adapting the
events of the 2012 avengers the battle
of new york actually in that change of
plans promo we saw more of the amazing
choreography including the guy playing
iron man levitating on a fly system
doing the same iron man repulsor pose
now if you want to start a business you
need a good online presence you want
people to know you're legit and not some
fly by night weirdo with a website from
1998 squarespace is the only one
platform to build a beautiful online
presence that belongs in 2020 when
squarespace lets you present members
only gated content connect your social
media accounts present video content and
all the other cool features to give you
a super cool super functional website
for your hobby or your business
squarespace will even sell you a url
collect the emails of interested folks
and send custom newsletters to keep them
up to date on your very modern
activities that aren't all stuck in 1998
head to squarespace.com for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain that's squarespace.com new
rockstars for 10 off your first purchase
of a website or a domain then there's
this awesome stunt of kate bishop in her
ronin attire stomping a wine bottle in a
wine cellar to fling it into a dude's
face now this wine cellar location with
the rubble on the floor looks like it's
the same location as the wine cellar
secret auction that gets plowed into in
the previous trailer an auction that
i've speculated could be the auction
from the hawkeye comics where kingpin
among others bid on footage of hawkeye
assassinating someone in this case i'm
wondering if that footage being bid on
could be video evidence from clint's
assassin days during the blip which
would expose that ronin assassin as one
in the same clint barton something that
could really complicate his relationship
with his family and his whole legal
status now in the comics the auction was
arranged by madame mask who i think vera
farmiga will be playing a version of as
kate's mother eleanor bishop she's
sipping wine in the shot obviously a
wine cellar would be a location she
might know her way around and with her
wealthy aura it is telling that her
daughter lives in a less prosperous
housing situation suggesting she doesn't
want to take her mother's money or was
cut off either way some tension between
these two there's another shot of kate
firing her tennis ball arrow at that
bell rope to ring it and now the hooks
at the end of the arrow spin in a way
that kind of make him look like a
propeller guiding the arrow on a
trajectory yeah clearly she's someone
who loves customizing her arrows and is
super delighted to find hawkeye's trick
arrows like a kid in a toy box and
there's more of that car chase also from
the fraction aha comics clint runs over
an inflatable tube santa outside the
christmas tree park saying sorry santa
definitely wants to get off that naughty
list and he gives kate some trick arrows
to fire at that van trust a bro moving
company which i pointed out before is a
nod to the tracksuit dracula's always
adding bro to their sentences and then
back in the apartment they're all
dressed festively including lucky the
pizza dog also from the comics and we
get a better look at that poster on the
wall a movie called creature of a dark
galaxy with cast names including looks
like milora brandon and loki ballard has
a couple weird names is this some loki
variant from this universe who acts in
sci-fi horror movies that we've never
heard of and now clint with frozen food
taped all over him including what looks
like a bruised wrist raises a purple mug
just nice to see clint finally
color-coded with purple after the mcu
for so long avoided that comic color the
man looks good and purple now the one
detail we have yet to see in any promo
footage is florence pugh as the elena
biloba who was last seen tasked by val
to hunt down clint barton in that black
widow post-credits scene pugh is
confirmed to return in this series but i
am wondering if she could be like a one
episode cameo and then they go their
separate ways kind of like ahsoka tano's
one episode arc in the mandalorian
season two let me know your favorite
part from this trailer and you can
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at avos follow new
rockstars and subscribe for breakdowns
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you